Since every Linux machine comes
with the user name root and
that user is super powerful, they can
do anything they want on this machine.
It's very common to disable the ability
to remotely log in as root.
Instead, we'll log in as
a user we create, and
then we can run individual commands
as root by using another command.
This is to make any potential
attacker's job a little more difficult
by eliminating the username that they
already know exists on this on this box.
Our vagrant virtual machine has already
set up the security pattern for us and
many other cloud providers
will do this for you, as well.
If not, it's highly advised that this be
one of the very first things you do when
you're setting up a new server.
We'll cover exactly how
to do that a bit later.
>> Let's run that same command again,
except this time we'll prepend the
command with this pseudo command here.
Now we see the results.
The pseudo command ran this
command as if we were root.